[Musique]
on a appris aujourd'hui avec stupeur la
terrible agression de thierry olive ce
sympathique agriculteurs qui s'était
fait remarquer dans l'émission de m6
l'amour est dans le pré
moi j'ai c'est de retrouver un hacker
qui est prêt à prendre l'homme et a tiré
aurait été agressé chez lui par un homme
qui le menaçait avec une hache site
hérisson est sorti indemne il est encore
sous le choc
l'agression qui n'est pas un cas isolé
souvenez-vous de mathieu et alexandre de
candidats de la même émission qui avait
reçu des menaces de mort à cause de leur
orientation sexuelle
et on a reçu des messages mais on va
vous rien pour châtier bonifier le
rookie lui aussi avait été alpagués
sauvagement dans la rue par un soi
disant journalistes
en pleine polémique des gilet jaune
j'appelle les flics autres célébrités
autre agression avec laurent romejko le
présentateur de l'émission des chiffres
et des lettres qui avait reçu un
courrier un peu particulier de la part
d'un déséquilibré un courrier anonyme
avec un poignard peu dans ce pack all
des agressions et des menaces qui se
font fréquentes lorsqu'on est connue
alors la notoriété est elle dangereuse
ce soir quéré olive est avec nous il va
nous raconter ce qu'il s'est passé
exactement
[Musique]
alors thierry merci tv est avec nous
m'ont thierry olive la notoriété tels
dangereuse oui ou non vous avez vos
petites pancartes nous raconter ce qui
vous est arrivé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mon thiery eh
bien vous savez je suis venu le 13
octobre mais ce soir et ben si je suis
là c'est un miracle non oui le ciel
tombait sur la tête
j'étais les mains dans les poches dans
un chemin communal j'appelais les bêtes
les unes après les autres
il avait un voisin qui vient d'hériter
des terres de sa mort 1
alors été dans son champ et brûler ses
franges tout ça mais chacun fait son
boulot moi la paix et voilà je souhaite
que du bonheur de nom mais du pays bas
depuis la première émission j'ai jamais
vu ça j'ai toujours entendu les paroles
de gauche à travers en parler on parlait
de vous aimer ça ne s'invente pas
l'épaule gauche que ça soit pas l'épaule
droite d'accord y'a pas de problème à
voir l'achat bois et une lame de 15 cm
de coupe et un an de 50 centimètres et
que le gore
j'avais vu comme je suis traversée va
chez lui c'est qu'il faisait dans son
champ ping était dans le bas du champ au
chpo moi j'attends mes bêtes pied mais
la première api 3e 4e
elle monte les champs carré mode son
champ à l'autre bout il a laissé le
traiteur dans le champ et moi j'ai
tellement schéma communal et vu qu'il
n'y ait ça tombe bien j'ai à te parler
nassar faut lui est si bas et à mon avis
elle dut d'avoir un petit peu les
émissions l'amour dans le pré qui
commençait sur quelques jours avant et
ça qu'a commencé lundi
moi c'était samedi à 10 heures moi j'ai
les mains dans les poches mais des lotus
a amené en courant et puis voici je vais
te faire tourner à faire vas-y h
quand j'ai eu lieu à shah presque à 20
cm 53 ans j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
rires quaïda foulée il a voulu vous avez
à peu de choses près j'avais de tête un
second barrel et après je vais pas les
choses qu'est ce qui vous a dit pourquoi
parfois
et latin au bocal et dit je n'ai pas
c'est donc parce que lui viendra voir
les terres 1er janvier ces terres là
c'était loué à nos agriculteurs qui a
fait faillite mais bon moi je m'en fous
et ils viennent d avoir le monsieur il
est maçon et travaille tout de la
semaine avec 5 et dimanche 6 mars est il
en train de débroussailler ça moi je
pense à ce moment là mercier tout
larnack de du monde quoi mais parce que
tu racontes
c'est vrai que c'est exceptionnel mais
cette semaine non mais c'est grave
mais pourquoi le mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font pour quoi et on voulait obama
voulait parce que j'étais la bonne poire
ce jour là j'ai manqué de passe à la
casserole à la prochaine fois que tu
penses qu'il était jaloux ta notoriété
les pistes jalloud est mauvais il ya un
visage gris tir est restée bois je ne
sais pas mais vous la dirai à vous je
mais avant je connaissais pas philippe
ribera le 1er janvier
l'ennemi moi quand je vois les dans son
champ moi je vais je suis pas curieux je
m'en fous je n'ai jamais j'ai jamais
parlé portez jamais je n'ai jamais
ressenti plat j'ai jamais par l est
vous savez aujourd'hui je passe elle a
les mains dans les poches vides à
j'écoutais petits oiseaux et sa
formidable de notre chemin dès
aujourd'hui on peut être agressés chez
nous mais kenya raison est ce que vous
allez porter plein de séries générales
et pas fier dé la gendarmerie et
candidate à la mairie
les gens ont droit tous
alors non thierry j j'ai un gendarme
alors je te le dire on rigole parce que
tu es corps personnages ou les maisons
le droit de parler droit de tout faire
aujourd'hui oui ça va faire le 14 avril
ouais je au printemps dernier j'ai je me
retrouvais un bâtiment vinci gtm tchité
chagny parce que moi je suis à fait
internet animé le land le cas fort à une
heure du matin à peine la mineur de
matane a reçu un coup de téléphone très
bâtiments agricoles
ça brûlait oui à tout gomorrhe un
tracteur au maire d'aulnay away allergie
à l'achat j'étais pas la cenap pas
c'était pas la passe et la sacra mais du
roi
heureusement tout va bien maintenant
mais ça aurait pu être grave alors
thierry est ce que ça aurait pu très
grave
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est parce
que bon on en rigole parce que thierry
c'est un personnage chan a été bon non
rigole mais on a pu leur aide moi des
fois comme assez de lits surtout que ce
sort d'hôpital elle avait été de 7 ans
j'ai dit si jamais une fois que tu es là
dedans pas bien sûr à temps je peux
copeaux mettre ma chaussette parce que
la hanche et sur des boîtes avec je ne
sais pas ce que c'est sans doute écarté
ce type on sait où il est maintenant il
habite à côté de chez moi à oui mais du
coup c'est toujours dangereux mais oui
parce que je vais vous aider à
aujourd'hui saâd arrêts et en plus en
plus si chasse à la préfecture qui
enlève son père mitch a oui c'est apollo
theater de l'oppression qui aura passé
c'est sûr merci pour ta vie s'il a
permis de chasse non métier aujourd'hui
la chasse et la raison on n'espère pas
et c'est important que vous le dis j'ai
thierry et on voulait te recevoir ce que
je dis pas ce que je suis vivant soir
ouais mais veulent réellement samedi je
pensais pas du tout est sécurisé de nous
appeler il nous a dit voilà j'aimerais
bien y arriver
en tout cas ça voilà c'est aussi non
mais on en rigole nous parce que
caractérise effets de la télévision 6 un
petit moteur et c'est vrai que derrière
il ya des jalousies mais voilà il vous
l'a dit parce que vous avez vus à la
télé vous
oui oui c'est pas parce que tu passes à
la télé tout ça et c'était samedi à 10h
sac arrivait et il avait déjà fait des
rediffusions qui est ça le passé lundi
soir
moi moi j'ai dit j'ai dit si tu aimes
pas cette émission là on regarde la
verdure tant qu'à regarder casimir après
tout je m'en fous moi j'suis pas d'amis
moi j'aime toutes les émissions un
ancien maire thierry vous êtes vivant
fait attention quand même mais je suis
vivant mais je suis pas sur dix vivent
longtemps avec un type comme ça alors
sans les parades chef il faut porter pas
il ya une blague c'est branché la la
plainte
merci en tout cas de faux témoignages
thiery mais cyril moi je tais toi qui as
voulu venir parce que tu m'as dit mon
échec merci si elle était toujours là
pour toi j'ai ça fait ça fait quand même
peur aujourd'hui je sais pas ce que tu
sais que quand vous avez passé des
missions pôle enfant qui a été battu par
dix j'ai eu une fille la tombe était
quant à lui perdu sa môme à 10 ans et
l'enfant gâté grave il y avait un jour
dit presque pleuré c'est normal moi
j'étais prêt à monter à paris pour
donner soutien à la famille un ami
thierry tu manges adore les enfants tu
m'as tu m'as tu m'appelles tu m'as
demandé voilà de douala je voulais faire
parce que ça aurait été là pour nous et
tu me fais rire je te le dis mais il lui
être pareil parce que tu es un
personnage exceptionnel moi je t'adore
et tu me fais rire aux larmes
je ne vois que tu viens citan moindre
problème avec ce garçon qui n'hésite pas
à nous appeler mais oui si on peut faire
si j'ai reçu à la balle dans ses seins
et raté n'inquiète pas moins inquiète
pas il fait peur le type t'inquiète pas
badgés pourtant que mon père vous savez
je suis comme un braconnier toujours sur
fort boyard n'importe quoi rien ne fait
peur même et là vous avez le choix fusil
devant vous voilà j'ai vu et puis à
briller bien j'ai dit moi je venais à
voir la prothèse blanche si une fois que
pilate dans mes tiroirs parti à l'autre
qu'avons nous tenait au courant et vous
restez vigilants c'est bien que vous
soyez venu témoigner sol est là je pense
qu'il va se calmer aussi parce qu'il va
dire que ça y est l'affairé publique
donc ça va être compliqué merci thierry
d'entrée c'est moi qui vous remercie et
géré il géra juste un petit mot
j'aime alors parce qu'il ya tellement de
gens qui ont envoyé des messages sur
l'internet celle ci à tour des livres il
ya toujours des livres de chez michel
lafon
ah oui parce qu'il y en a toujours
michel lafon a dit on a toujours en
disponibilité va très bien aux livres
wallays fait un livre merci à michel ses
fans on doit on doit y aller le verso
logis ça valait le petit je veux être un
petit peu heureux je demande pas et bien
totalité sinon tu peux c'est très bien
merci
[Applaudissements]